all right let's go to sarah in grand
rapids michigan so tell me how i can
help this morning
okay so my son is five years old i got
married when he was one and a half
and then when he was three my husband
adopted him
but my question is how and when
do we tell our son
wow that's a great question thank you
for your trust here
um so who is his birth father
i'm just a random man okay
does does that random man know about
his son yeah okay and so that man has
chosen i don't to not be in his life in
any way shape form or fashion
yeah okay and so on his birth
certificate when your
now husband adopted him is that is his
name reflected on your son's birth
certificate
yes okay so i called again
i've got a team of counselors across the
country that i will check in with
with sometimes when i know there's going
to be a challenging question or one that
i don't have
some direct experience with or that i
think i've got some opinions on but i
want to make sure i'm getting the right
wisdom
and again i checked with my good friend
lynn jennings what she does
for a living is have hard conversations
with kids
and she talks about parental right
terminations and she talks about
abuse situations and she walks kids
through court processes and so she's a
savant when it comes to these things and
i actually sat down with her and said
hey walk me through
how we would imagine the situation here
and so
um there's several ways you can do this
none of which are going to be awesome
and none of which are going to be the
end of all things
but the what you don't ever want to do
when your son is
16 17 or 18 is have him turn around and
think my mom
lied to me right and so it's you're a
saint for even thinking about this
um here were some some recommend
recommendations here some ideas
one is wait until the child's old enough
to fully process
the emotions that are going to be there
if a a dad is present if a dad might
show back up in a situation which you
don't want to do for a five-year-old or
a six-year-old and there's actually some
children's books that help these
conversations along
you don't want them to get surprised in
this situation where it sounds like
birth date is 100 out of the picture
completely out of the loop
and your your child your son has a
awesome guy who's present in his life
who has adopted him who is fully
invested as his
daddy um that's not going to be the case
and so um the recommendation is
10 to 12 maybe a little bit older when
you would sit down and have that
conversation but what i would recommend
is that you start planting seeds now
and what planting seeds looks like is
your new husband your
the father of this little boy the daddy
of this little boy
starts today and he may already do this
he starts telling him today
every day i am so grateful that i chose
you
that i chose to be your daddy
i'm so grateful i chose to be your dad
and he's going to do that every single
day
of that little boy's life and when you
talk about
his daddy you're going to talk about can
you believe that you are
so perfect and so wonderful and so
loved that your daddy chose you
god chose mommy and god chose daddy and
daddy chose you
and what we're going to do is we're
going to build up a bank
one year two year three years five years
six years
worth of insight on that little boy
understanding that his daddy chose him
so that one day when the conversation
happens and that
when that conversation begins anybody
can be a father
anybody can father a child but very few
men
step up and become a daddy and this guy
chose to then when your son understands
that disconnection when he start
understands asking questions and those
things that are natural and right and of
course they're going to happen
but he will be tethered in deeply with
his
dad and then you're gonna have these
life experiences these developmental
things these
you know the spiritual bases all of
these are different and i would also
recommend when you decide to have this
conversation if it's something you're
gonna plan and not something that pops
back
up um there are people like my friend
lynn there are people
all over the country who are especially
skilled
at teaching little kids where they come
from and why they come from where they
come from
and it depends on what life has been
like for them
what you know their spiritual values if
are they people of faith are they not
um developmentally are they so you know
they're very mature ten-year-olds
they're very immature ten-year-olds and
they are excellent at
breaking some of these conversations in
there and letting kids slowly and gently
absorb and hear these things
at the same time know that they're safe
and tethered in and so
tell me about this guy that you married
is he awesome
yes does he love that little boy
yes that's awesome good for you and
good for freaking him good for him for
choosing your little boy
and choosing to become an extraordinary
dad tell me about your little boy
um he likes tractors he's
like music he's
just active rambling
so your little boy is a smiling fun
excited little boy he's got a daddy who
loves him
he's got a mommy who loves him
sarah i just want to honor your heart
when do i tell them how do i tell them
having hard honest conversations with
children is challenging
again in this situation every day he
needs to know
not only told but he needs to feel he
needs to see your eye contact he needs
to feel your touch
lots of touch on his face lots of touch
on his feet lots of hugs
but i want his dad this man who chose
him i want every day of his life
this guy to look your son in the eye and
say i'm so glad i chose to be your daddy
i get to be your dad and again 10
11 12 maybe a little bit older depending
on again developmental life things
um you're gonna sit down with an expert
who's gifted at talking to kids like my
good friend
dr lyndon jennings and you're all gonna
have that conversation together
and then it's gonna be totally natural
for
your son to want to meet his birth dad
someday your son to want to reach out
your son's going to have questions about
why did my daddy not want me
i mean why did my original father what
was it about me
that made him not want to be around and
when he has those questions which are
natural and they are good and they are
understandable
he will be completely anchored and
tethered in to the fact that he is loved
by two parents who care for him
and two parents that choose to love him
every day